hey I was gonna breasts my name is Pippa
welcome to troll face quest video memes
oh man what a great title if only my
video tile were as good anyway this is
uncut in the but it's a new thing I'm
trying out where no matter what happened
no matter what events take place or if I
get stuck or if I don't know this place
explodes I will keep playing uncut
there will be no cuts in this video is
for wanna try to say Jesus Christ I
would have cut that out already
I'm sweating I don't know why I put so
much pressure on me but I did one before
uh it drove me insane but a lot of you
brothers enjoyed it so I thought we'd do
it again on this game apparently I am in
this game that's the main reason I'm
playing this obvious I don't know why
anyone would be surprised that is why if
that okay here we got troll face quest
troll tube that's the celeste shitty
title uh I think that's supposed to be
me I think that me right here not the
hipster guy that well I guess bump them
a hipster I got the rug rat face okay uh
play play game yes the story is as
follows still a better love story than
me and Edgar
yeah I would have bedded that out that's
turbo okay ah so this is a kind of like
point-and-click oh it's scary maze isn't
it
damn those eyebrows though those
eyebrows on fleek
yo this is scary maze game everyone just
play this dumb scam so spooky I mean we
okay we fail then we need to do
something that does not fail
we already click 50 times Jesus Christ
oh wow that was easy
JEP you know just brofist away if you
ever get stuck or if you're ever in
danger brofist to the face see this is
why when you know when it when I do the
outro never brofist too hard cuz this is
what happens you break your monitor okay
next one I am not familiar with this one
but I merely notice this nice bulge over
here so that's that's nice I don't know
if you can see my mouse or not I hope
you can see the mouse that will
otherwise I'm clicking on the bad thing
and I'm clicking on that okay one for
you one for me one for me
so I'm thinking right now did I set my
recording so you can see my mouse and
what I would do is that I would stop the
recording to check it but yeah I'm gonna
work I'm here all right I'm still here
the gameplay is okay I got a make sure
cuz I don't want to [ __ ] feet it's
out of god damn I hate this yeah you can
see my mouse 3 2 1
recording ok there we go we're back hey
okay let's keep coming uh alright so
this is what I blend guy isn't it though
I haven't seen him in a couple years
honestly it's got an apple or a banana I
guess so this guy blends the different
like expensive item and see if it blends
or not there's so many can I take a
second there's so many stupid stupid
channels that does this they take
expensive items they either blow them up
saw them up hey [ __ ] pour acid on
them and see what happens
what do you think is gonna happen they
get destroyed they get millions of years
I don't understand maybe I should parody
that I think that would be a funny
parody that's a good idea actually I
think I'll do that
alright what do we do put his dick in no
there must be something
now hold on why don't we got in three
three one zero another phone wait a
second that the Nokia the mean phone
that doesn't break get out of here
okay I'm guessing that said cuz this
game is literally all about the meat now
I'm pretty well worse than me yet see
there you go okay we did it pretty
[ __ ] awesome might sighs writing me
on skype I promised I would pick her up
uh but I'm afraid of looking at my skype
that it will show up in the gameplay and
no and cut no matter why okay um we're
trying to take a [ __ ] doesn't seem to be
working what is this guy's problem
I see a rocket ship in the background so
I think I have an idea what's gonna
happen I don't know what video ad this
is like Mentos and Coke or something
there's got to be oh well then what is
that a remote control what
oh oh I did not expect that that's
pretty awesome okay well we did another
one I've been pretty well I did not
expect this I thought we would get stuck
all the time I feel like I just jinxed
myself but at all right Miley Cyrus
wrecking ball
I feel like oh yeah that's definitely a
fail surely Pinsk
my favorite country wait what am I
supposed to do there's a walkthrough
oh well then free advertisement wait I
gotta wash your sponsor to watch the
walkthrough you know what [ __ ] you all
right I'm gonna figure this someone out
it's uncut in the bud I don't care how
long it takes I'm gonna regret this so
much I know it I know it there's
something [ __ ] you there's something
else I'm supposed to click on up up
oh poor Maile she's terrified
yeah I'd cut my ass [ __ ]
see I know how to do this [ __ ] Oh God
inside from Poquette rep you know what
the [ __ ] Essenes ah that's my face oh my
neck [ __ ] hurts okay okay uh let's
try something else
what what what I'm speechless
yes earnest they're supported by the man
that I love the awkward beard thank you
thank you for that eight silver games or
whatever [ __ ] who made this uh I'm ready
with the breakfast I'm sure there's
gonna be a brofist here a [ __ ] safe
don't make me laugh like that yes that's
how I do commentary dad dad dad yeah I
feel like I can just put this picture up
here and I'll cut it in the bud I don't
even have to be here thank you for
making my hair like a [ __ ] swoosh as
well uh alright what if never again I
see some screws over here
what that's my old microphone as well um
I still have it I just peeked way too
much when I yell like an idiot all right
so what do I do
I don't I'll wait I'll wait I see it
there's a little thing here I don't
think I have one of those I'm pretty
sure what no no no no no I know what you
think this is not real this game is
fabrication there's not a weird little
sleepy guy in my head what that [ __ ]
game what the [ __ ] are you on about what
the [ __ ] are you trying to tell me you
could have done anything
brofist the barrels Edgar
that's however is not a thing [ __ ] you
all right
I'm gonna jump some [ __ ] drop some salad
that's actually no salad in that what
you don't like my salad with the [ __ ] a
certain order to this it looks the same
either way
that's disgusting
what a bit of that now it's that what is
this game about why am i that market boy
slow mo this is sound like him and slow
mo guys I don't [ __ ] I'll be recording
what am I supposed to record something
is getting tricky I don't want to [ __ ]
up now we've been doing so well
walkthrough no no no no what's that
[ __ ]
okay now that's how you make youtube
videos just like that if I could do an
uncut I would have edited in myself new
a night Oh awful okay uh whatever get
icebucketchallenge
a lot of thumbs up in this video why do
I always try the same thing okay what
about now sinner what bucket jollies
ever today ah [ __ ] [ __ ] a replay how
many of these are there I click four
hundred times why do I keep clicking ah
I can't [ __ ] [ __ ] you huh damn it
shut up oh god I'm setting to sweat I
feel like we're not gonna do
[ __ ] don't tell me throw a bucket
challenge or throw them you know what
it's strike shrek is distracting me over
here okay now he went away [ __ ] you he
is there I prepped I predicted that is
stupid shrek you're right you know what
I'm gonna go God ever my hyung cut in
the butt but I can move it I can move it
well thing now what hello help Bruce
hello help never my other you are thank
you your farmers apparently oh the
garbage challenge the garbage bin
challenge
see this is the one to collect this is
the one to raise awareness of of
Alzheimer's uh game completed oh oh ten
minute blank Wow damn damn son wait I
should get like a soundboard when I do
oh I have one
okay wait yes
yes we did it
okay well that was uncut in the bun oh
I'm so happy
ah okay well that was pretty cool
I really enjoy that let me know if you
enjoy uncut in the butt I would very
much appreciate if you leave a like if
you did and maybe I'll do more of these
thank you both so much for watching and
as always that's always uh where's my
soundboard and stay awesome press